keeping it simple in the kitchen doesn't
mean you can't have amazing food that
not only looks incredible but tastes
fantastic too
my first recipe is so easy it removes
the stress from cooking and is a
pleasure to make chili beef lettuce
wraps
cooking should never be a chore the more
you cook the more confident you become
that way you actually start to enjoy it
and that's the key to good cooking have
a bit of fun along the
way this is minced beef and minced pork
the pork needs to sit in there otherwise
the beef's gonna dry out
it's really important to season the
mince before you cook it
pan nice and hot
a touch of olive oil
mince in
breaking up like that really helps to
sort of separate it so we can fry it off
with a lot of color
with your spoon
just go through
and start breaking that up
the most important thing to remember is
mint is made up of cheap cuts brisket
belly
short rib so
it needs help
and frying off the mince for color
it's so important
if this pan wasn't hot your mince is
going to boil it's a horrible gray color
on there
and there's no flavor on your mince
taste a little bit
[Music]
tastes delicious it's seasoned
beautifully see how crispy it's going
take it
much further than you ever taken mince
before nice and crispy
smells incredible
i'm draining it it's crucial it keeps
the mints nice and crispy and you get
rid of that
excess fat
that's lovely
now
just wipe out the pan then wash it low
gas
now we're going to add texture to the
mince
finely chopped chili
ginger
garlic and spring onions
spring onions give this sort of mince a
really nice freshness
because it just gives that crunch
nice and thinly
now i'm gonna fry off the chilis the
ginger the garlic first
sesame seed oil teaspoon only in
garlic chili ginger in
fry that off nicely
the sesame seed oil just lifts up the
whole flavour
brown sugar that starts to really
caramelize the chili the garlic and the
ginger
mince in
now
my fish sauce that gives it the
saltiness
you can see now why it's so important to
get that mince really crispy because
nothing's going soggy staying really
crispy
fresh lime
that makes the mince fragrant
and then
lime juice roll it
and squeeze that in there
[Music]
incredible i've got the salty
i've got the heat
i've got the sweetness now i've got the
acidicness as well and then finally my
spring onions in right at the last
minute so i've got crunch in there as
well
smells
amazing literally cook the mince now
with sort of 30 seconds
to go
off and take it out
looks incredible smells so inviting
[Music]
to go with the chili beef i'm making a
simple sweet and spicy dipping sauce so
everyone can dress the crispy mince to
their own taste
dipping sauce a little teaspoon
the brown sugar soy sauce
gives it a nice sort of dark rich color
sesame seed oil
a tablespoon and just top that up with a
tablespoon
of olive oil
that stops the sesame seed all becoming
too rich a teaspoon
of fish sauce and then a touch of chili
leave the seeds in again i want the heat
in that sauce
so impressive an amazing show off center
piece
lime juice
in
in the coriander chop it through once
give that little mix up
just check the seasoning
that's lovely nice and rich
now the lettuce i'm going to use baby
gem because it's really nice and durable
and sort of quite strong
so you just sort of sit
these nice
trimmed lettuce leaves
around
now the exciting part to serve take your
lettuce up
spoon in
your mince and then
a little touch of dressing
just a little drizzle
nice and that's the secret of having
good easy relaxed food is that
you just help yourself
food that looks and tastes a million
bucks doesn't have to be complex
this dish is as fun to cook as it is to
eat
[Music]
first get prepped
chopped garlic
ginger and chili
keeping the seeds for extra kick
slice spring onions
chopped spring greens
and trim ahead of broccoli
then whisk two eggs
prep done stir fry on
add a good lug of oil to a hot pan
garlic
ginger chili
next the spring greens and broccoli
add water to steam
[Music]
then cook rice this dish is perfect for
using leftover rice
make a well
add the eggs
spring onions
and a dash of fish sauce
[Music]
scramble then mix
season
[Applause]
top with lime and spring onions
[Music]
my fragrant fried rice
made simple with advanced prep and ready
in five minutes
this fantastic fast and simple pasta
dish made with everyday ingredients just
goes to prove you can eat good food
whenever you want
really important put the water on first
so you can just have it gently simmering
away ready for the pasta
while the water comes to the boil start
the sauce by slicing mushrooms first off
fingers
one in front two behind
up and down
then add olive oil to a hot frying pan
[Music]
i want that nice color on the mushrooms
off the heat literally 10 seconds and
when you toss something really important
you get all the ingredients at the end
of the pan
push down and pull back
that noise that's
that's all the water coming out of the
mushrooms
next finely chop a fat clove of garlic
[Music]
then prepare your leeks
just take your knife
and go down through the center turn it
over
and again into quarters
see all that opening up and then just
rinse the top of that to get rid of any
potential dirt or sand
it just breaks up into nice little
quarters
add
all that leek
into those mushrooms
beautiful
and now
the secret is to get rid of that water
inside the leek
as it cooks down all the water's gone
you just let that really nice intense
flavor
garlic's got nice and crispy now we're
going to add a touch of chicken stock in
there
beautiful
lasagna sheets i'm just going to drop
the sheets
in to the water
lasagna sheets are an unusual choice for
a dish like this but they work
brilliantly although any type of pasta
you've got in the cupboard will do
and just twist that pan
that stops any pasta actually sticking
to the bottom of the pan
chicken start to reduce down by half
and it's almost delayed the bottom of
the pan basically washed all that
wonderful flavor off turn the gas down
and add a couple of tablespoons of cream
this just enriches the dish bring it
back up to the ball and let it simmer
for three to four minutes
now
the secret with the pasta is just taking
it out a little early
so you've got that nice texture
hold up the sheet and just nip it
and you can feel your fingers in the
center it's ready
turn the sauce down and lay
these beautiful sheets
of lasagna into that sauce
i'm just going to turn the gas off now
and let the pasta sit in there and
absorb that amazing sauce
finish with chopped fresh tarragon
it's a delicious herb it goes
brilliantly well mushrooms and leeks
just let that sit and almost sort of
infuse
to serve i'm making a quick bruschetta
by toasting fresh chipata bread two nice
slices drizzle that
in olive oil
a little bit of garlic
just rub the bread
the crust as well crust is what really
takes that garlic
now pan for the bread a little touch of
olive oil
as it starts to smoke
bread in
[Music]
but look at the pasta now it's been
stained by that amazing sauce to serve i
want a nice spoon of my mushrooms leeks
and cream then i'll take my pasta
just twist it
and let it sit on top
that tarragon has just lifted everything
bread on
and that's the beauty about something so
simple that can be done in 20 minutes
with everyday ingredients a stunning
pasta dish
adding easy and versatile dishes like
this to your repertoire is what cooking
at home is all about so you can always
make great tasting food at the drop of a
hat
it's brilliant to have a number of great
recipes up your sleeve to rely on and
let's be honest we've all got a tin of
sweetcorn somewhere so i'm going to show
you how to make the most amazing fritter
[Music]
first off the mixture
take your flour sieve
really important to sieve the flour that
stops the mixture from having any lumps
in there
just before you get to the end
i want to put
half a teaspoon of baking powder the
baking powder gives the mixture some
lift
in
and just sieve that through
a touch of salt
and pepper
next an egg
about four tablespoons of milk
and give that a little whisk
now just put a little drizzle
of olive oil in there that helps to
relax the mixture
whisk that in make sure we got rid of
all those lumps
so that i want a nice smooth
almost like a cake mixture okay next
take the seeds out of a chili to lower
the heat roll the chilli so give it a
really good
shake
[Music]
tap them out
slice
in half
into quarter and each quarter
in half
and chop through
it's a really nice quick way
of slicing a chili
into the mixture spring onion
take off that outside layer of the
spring onion top and tail slice it in an
angle
it's a little bit of texture running
through the mixture i want that nice
crunch
in coriander
just slice through
nice and gently
and get that in there
next to the sweetcorn now drain it from
the tin and just pat it dry so it
doesn't make the mixture too wet
give that a nice mix
you can see now i've got two thirds
ingredients
and one third of the mixture to bind
together that's the secret of good
frittata so you're
you're biting into excitement and not
sort of dough
pan on
olive oil in
and hot
get a nice big dessert spoon you know
there's one nice portion
in
space the fritters evenly around the pan
in a clockwise direction so you always
know which one to turn first
just with the back of your spoon sort of
spread them out a little bit
okay
palette knife
just check
happy with the color
and turn over
beautiful
now for the chili yogurt dressing
deseed and finely chop a red chili
and add to a pot of natural yogurt
[Music]
and then some fresh lime
[Music]
finish with chopped coriander
coriander in
and give that a nice mix up
that chili just lifts it
the lime gives it that nice tanginess
the fritters
they smell amazing and with the sauce
it tastes fantastic
that is such a delicious recipe using a
tin of sweet corn from your cupboard
amazing
you